CATHERINE DRENNAN: For 5.111,
we created this video series,
and we called it, Behind
the Scenes at MIT.
And there are two
kinds of videos.
One where undergrads,
graduate students, post-docs,
or another faculty
member are talking
about how the basic chemical
principles we're learning
about in the class are used
in their laboratory or by them
and how those chemical
principles will
make the world a better place.
DARCY WANGER: My
name is Darcy Wanger,
and I work as a graduate student
in the Bawendi lab at MIT.
I work with quantum
dots in my research.
Quantum dots are really,
really tiny particles
of a semiconductor.
People in our lab are working
to make quantum dots bind
to a tumor.
So when a doctor goes
in to remove a tumor,
they can see, just
shining a UV light on it,
and see whether
it's all gone when
they've taken out the tumor.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
It was interesting
because I talked to
some of the students
in the class about their sort
of perceptions of things.
And then, after they
had watched the videos,
sort of what they thought.
And a lot of students actually
said, I was wondering.
You're learning
this, and it's good,
it builds character
to learn something
that could be
challenging but wondered,
am I ever going to
use this for anything?
And then they started watching
these videos and seeing this,
and they're like, oh, yes.
This is used all the time.
It could be used in my
undergraduate research.
People are doing this.
This is a subject that
people are actively
learning new things.
And I feel like this is a
question for a lot of intro
classes, because you have
these thick textbooks
and you sort of
feel like everything
that could have been learned,
it seems like it's all there.
Like volume 2.
There are three laws
of thermodynamics.
Are people trying to
find a fourth law?
What is someone who do
chemistry research-- what
are they actually doing?
Discovering?
No, we know what the
electrons are already.
And so this gave people
a sense of what people
were using chemistry for now.
What were those
current questions.
And when I was a high
school teacher originally,
that was really what I wanted.
What are people doing now?
What are the key questions?
If I was studying chemistry,
what would I be doing?
And I want to help
create this material
so other people can see that.
Because for some people,
if you tell them it's hard
and it's a challenge to
learn, they'll just learn it.
And if they don't use it--
it could be like Latin,
it builds character, it's
fine, it's a dead language
but OK, I'm going
to get in there.
But then for other
people, they really
want to know that this
is going to be useful.
And if they're going
to really invest in it,
they want to know
that it's important
and they can do things.
And MIT students and I think
so many people out there
want to make the
world a better place.
There are a lot of really
wonderful human beings.
And they need the
tools, and they
want to do something
that's important.
So I want to create
those tools for them
to learn this so that they
can apply it and do something
and they can see the
power of chemistry.